several number five your income depends
on the value that you provide another
really important one lease in my opinion
the more you can help a client the more
money you're going to make and they will
pay a premium over existing suppliers if
you can provide them with more value and
this is where a lot of entrepreneurs
make the mistake where they just want to
make a lot of money but they're not
actually helping their clients out that
much and if you look back to that very
first startup rule that we created it
was how much do you love it and then
also how much does it help your
potential customers and so the more you
able to help them more value can provide
the more likely you're going to be make
a lot more money which is probably an
important goal for a lot of you who are
listening here on the call today so
that's important a quick example for my
experience and a recent one I was asked
to create a blog post for some of my
corporate clients and they came to me
and said we'd like you to write for our
blog and said sure and they said we'll
pay you five hundred dollars to do it is
that ok let's let's do it and I started
doing I thought great why not you know
get a link back from my site and I
didn't just write the bear munim and
this is important so I was going up
against maybe 10 of people who they had
also hired I was one of 10 bloggers and
they thought okay well they're all the
same they're all bloggers throw some
content and hope it works the important
thing that I did was tried to add a lot
more value so as an example they said we
need three to five hundred words i wrote
1,500 words to thousands of words i
wrote way more than you expected i added
a video nobody else added a video and
then I've promoted the content so I sent
it to my newsletters I sent it to my
Twitter i sent it to my facebook youtube
when i'm sure a lot of you listening
have read some of that content and
hopefully you liked it so the shameless
entrepreneur profiles and we had all
this momentum building up and if you
compare the articles that we write
compared to the Articles that other
bloggers right we're blowing them away
it's like 10 times the amount of page
use 100 times the amount of comments
it's really crazy how much better our
content doesn't give everybody else so
when the king
time to renewing a contract in through
green okay where do we go next year of
course I want to come to us and we also
increase their prices so now it's five
times I have to be able to IRS to create
content for their site all the content
that we create as always value add it's
never need to go by American Express
products or whatever it is it's all
value add but we were able to increase
our pricing in a pretty competitive
world by a huge factor and it's because
we provided so much extra value to our
clients and they didn't even know they
needed that bad they just came and said
we want a blog post so I said okay and
then we've started going way above and
beyond what they expected so there's an
opportunity for you as an entrepreneur
if you can get a client especially a
corporate client to start I love going
out the corporate clients because they
can be a bigger price ticket for you
they can they can spend more with you
and if you become an important part of
their business they're going to keep
bringing you back so it's a great way to
get introduced and start building up
that business but if you can do it and
then slowly start expanding how much
work you do with them so you start in a
small scale and you over deliver like
crazy so you offer a tiny little project
something that's meaningless for them
but for you is important and you don't
make a lot of money on your first
project you over deliver like crazy you
you be the supplier that they've never
seen before they love working with you
you're so responsive and you're really
doing a lot of work that nobody else is
doing then you know there's gonna be
other opportunities to work with them
and earn more dollars and get more
referrals and do repeat projects so
that's really you're weighing as an
entrepreneur atty you go up against the
big guys you provide amazing service and
keep thinking of ways that you can
provide value to your customers beyond
what everybody else is doing so a lot of
that comes from talking to your
customers and understanding your market
so if you're getting into something new
that you have you know maybe passion for
but don't really know much about that's
why it's important to go and do those
things that get a job even on a
part-time basis so you understand the
industry and you able to figure out
other ways you can add value try to add
value on things that are sir
related as much as possible or things
that have high perceived value but don't
actually cost you a lot it's a quick
example every from my business every
order will pull together some research
on entrepreneurs just based on on my own
website and my own list of people there
are asking questions really common
question that are being asked and kind
of the trends that are happening in the
world of entrepreneurship and we use
that to help create our content schedule
point forward so if everybody's asking
about starting up will create webinars
on starting up and will create more
entrepreneur profiles and starting up
people asking about marketing will be
more marketing context so we're doing
this anyway for a business what I
started doing is working with our
corporate partners and I go and I do a
free presentation to them on our
findings so this is stuff that I'm
already doing doesn't take me a lot of
time to put together maybe make the
slides look a little nicer than what we
would do for own internal purposes but
i'm not spending a lot of extra time
doing it but it's huge value to my
clients nobody else is doing this for
them when we're getting a lot of
industry knowledge that can help them
plan their schedules as well so again is
going way above and beyond and anytime
somebody wants to work on a small
business entrepreneurship project
they're going to come and talk to us
because we're providing all this extra
body so same thing for you think of
other ways even if it doesn't cost you a
lot of time or money it will seem as
being really important and valuable to
your clients those are some of the best
ways to be able to go out and do it
because again doesn't cost you too many
resources so your income will definitely
depend on how much I provide and you
want to keep striving as much as you can
to provide tons of value to them